like everything humans are made up of
atoms but what's interesting is how we
behave so very similar to them atoms
share electrons with other atoms in
order to become stable and form covalent
bonds human relationships are just like
that of covalent bonds and reflect the
same process of give-and-take
relationships develop out of some divine
like push and pull when we allow it we
are magnetized towards other people that
are compatible with our polarity two
people become into one mutual life when
a stable bond is formed these bonds are
formed all through life attempting to
balance out all of our unstable forces
in the process in theory this is a
beautiful system that guarantees
balanced and receptive relationships
throughout life but then why does it
seem like there are so many challenges
associated with human social life
why is true friendship and partnership
so hard to find this challenge Rises out
of our insecurities and fears our fear
of being ourself and having others
dislike it but when we submit to this
fear and hide behind its wall we
inadvertently prevent our electron pairs
from being fully revealed to the world
our whole self hides behind the wall and
the polarized system of push and pull
becomes broken it is like someone
holding their hand in front of a camera
lens no one can see the subject
no one can enjoy the subject
for successful social relationships to
occur your whole image must be visible
by removing your hand from the lens you
reveal your true self to the world and
allow others to do the same if you want
people to truly care for you and allow
you to care for them you must be willing
to present your full self without fear
if instead you hide behind fears war you
will never find the stability and
connection we also desire in life
instead of forming balance like atoms
you will only form temporariness and
insecurity like a cigarette
your life will be smoked away by those
you encounter in life your ashes will be
flicked into the wind until nothing
remains you will treat others the same
way and feel slight and temporary
pleasure from your relationships but the
sensations will soon dissipate and you
will soon be left with nothing not
everyone is going to match with your
polarity in life except this do not
bother trying to force relationships
with those who do not
you must instead search only for those
who do match with your truest self like
when you are scanning the radio and come
across a station with poor reception you
must not stay and listen to the static
of meaningless social relationships
you must keep scanning until you find
value and clarity
you